paru titre fièrement maison de jacques
tati et c'est vrai que jacques tati a
séjourné dans cette maison ici tout le
monde ou presque a entendu parler du
cinéaste juif il était venu pendant la
guerre se réfugier à la campagne
trois familles juives y résidaient alors
les canes propriétaires y avait un
atelier de confection
c'était un endroit assez propice parce
qu'on était juste en limite de ligne de
démarcation
je pense que la présence de ces familles
juives ont fait que par amitié ils l'ont
certainement recueillies pendant cette
période un peu difficile
très vite il se lie d'amitié avec les
berrichons et leur promet de revenir et
de faire un film la guerre finie
en attendant il occupe une partie de la
maison et organise tout pour échapper à
d'éventuels raf va t'arriver
maintenant il y avait une trappe qui
permettait de passer derrière il ya
joignent à la grande cabane dans les
années 50 la maison est revendue à la
famille des actuels propriétaires jean
chopinet qui vit toujours à vision se
souvient moi personnellement je n'ai vu
qu'une fois mieux
une fois le terrain mais bien quand jean
et son frère ont mis la maison en vente
à la disparition de leur mère
et si la communauté de communes est bien
consciente de l'intérêt de cette
histoire dans l'élaboration du film
jours de fête
les nouveaux investissements prévus à
saint-sever aussi nous vivions sans trop
lourd pour penser la racheter